[Music]
we gotta talk about some uplifting
things with you we're gonna have a good
time pal okay let's do it
first of all I'm told you quit drinking
yes I did congratulate thank you wait
three days three days three days you
know like that I had I had four White
Russians before I got on a plane I was
in Hawaii
and I can't go on the beach cuz I'm so
pasty yeah and I was sitting there and
there was this other freckled loser
there and he was just drinking a White
Russian oh my god that looks delicious
right eighty degrees out little milk and
the food I hate flying so I just started
slamming these things and I don't really
remember the flight and every just once
in a while I just I just like pull it
back like one of those every once in a
while thing so yeah yeah stop mini you
know it's it's hard to stay sober in
this country it's just always something
coming up you know yeah guy I'm just
gonna get through the holidays get
through the holidays then you know they
don't they don't sober up then you get
the Super Bowl yeah this I got I got a
drink then that Valentine's Day I'll say
something dumb and then I'll start
drinking right st. Patty's Day it never
ends no sir
yeah it's terrible Ag day day
one day I'm not an alcoholic I just I
truly enjoy getting drunk every once in
a while you enjoy it and you can't stop
and that's an important thing not only
because I have free time
no okay time if I had like a kid or if I
had like like a real job
you'd pull it together yeah